High School football coach Joe Kennedy
was fired after silently praying on the
50-yard line what a heresy and this was
after football games in his high school
his case went all the way to the Supreme
Court and in a major win for Religious
Freedom the court sided with Mr Kennedy
now he's gotten his job back and this
Friday is his first game Bremerton High
School football coach Joe Kennedy Joe I
had you on that first week or second
week win or lose what are you going to
be doing after the game
well you know what I'm gonna do I am
going to give thanks I'm going to take a
knee
ings for being just being an American
being part of the football team and
having the constitutional right to
exercise the First Amendment and Joe our
Point always is look you have the right
to believe not believe if you're an
atheist and you're happy you know good
on you um if you're a Christian or a
member of another Faith then that works
for you that's that's freedom but you
were targeted
for your religious belief and the
response so far that I understand that's
going to be happening with this game
in a few days is going to be
overwhelming and how's that going to
feel
it's gonna it's gonna feel really great
just to be able to know that the the
First Amendment and free speech and the
freedom of religion is live and well for
all Americans like you said earlier uh
yeah politics is not going to be the one
to to save us God's got to save us we've
got to save ourselves we got to get off
our butts and it's just going to show
everybody that everybody that's prayed
hey we've won we won this together
and the fight goes on though um to all
the folks out there watching who kind of
wave their hands off at you and say oh
you're little miracle stories are nice
for you but you know it's that that
that's stupid stuff what do you say to
them tonight
yeah they're just not looking at God it
I I challenge everybody to take on God
just just try amounts the prove me wrong
and you'll see what Miracles they could
do in your lives if an average Joe like
me could do it imagine what everybody
else could do in America
coach can't wait to see what happens
with the team I'm hoping for the win so
keep in touch with us thanks so much hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else